all right good morning everybody welcome
to baby district council licensing
regulatory committee the 14th of august
2020 um first of all a bit of sad news
i'd like to give our condolences from
this committee
to sue carpendale who sadly lost her
husband last week
and our faults are with her and uh look
forward to seeing her back
on this committee when she feels like
coming back
right now we've got to do a bit of uh
housekeeping
first of all welcome to the virtual
meeting of the licensing
regulatory committee my first of all
remind you
of some of the domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
members are reminded not to use
the messaging chat function during the
meeting unless is
to report a pecuniary or non-petunia
interest or not to notify the chair or
to notify the chair that
you wish to make a proposal
that is if you are attending the meeting
to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by
the chair please await your turn
i would like to remind everybody present
that this meeting will be broadcasted
live to the internet and will be
capable of repeat viewing the whole of
the meeting will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by
the council to have consented to be
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also
consenting to being recorded by the
council and to
the possibility use of these sound
recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film or photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
right moving on uh what do your officers
like to
introduce themselves please
can you go through david david price
licensing officer
catherine catherine green licensing
officer
emma um emma's not
here today but she's being represented
by my colleague case okay if you'd like
to introduce yourself
okay sanders licensing officer okay
lovely nigel yeah nigel dulu legal
advisor committee
and obviously karen sayer governance
officer
i can move to the agenda now please
first of all um
can we do a roll call for attendance
please karen
thank you chair we have received
apologies from councillor carpendale and
councillor fraser
members please can you reply with good
morning or present when i call out your
names
councillor suez good morning
councillor peter beer
councillor beer i
i've mooted myself yes good morning
unpleasant thank you
councillor trevor creswell
i don't think he's here
oh councillor sean dawson
no councillor jane gould
good morning councillor margaret
mayberry
good morning councillor mark newman
yeah and counselor john nunn don't think
he's here either
okay thank you very much okay thank you
thank you move to decorations of
interest can you please raise your hand
anyone all right uh to confirm the
minutes
of the meeting of the 12th of june
are there any points regarding accuracy
of the meeting
could i have a proposal please
i'm going to move yeah
peter uh seconder
was that margaret no i'm try i'm trying
to query the accuracy but this
um oh it's my hand is raised now i'm
trying to um
comment on the accuracy of the minutes
okay well we'll move back to that then
what is your question
it's not really a question it's a
comment that i don't believe the minutes
um reflect the concerns that some
members
had for the subject that was being
discussed
at the time which was the uh taxi
fares yeah
well we've we've gone back and we're
looking at that but so what change would
you like to the minutes have you got one
uh yes i did write it down somewhere and
i would like it
um express that there were concerns
from members including the
um deputy chairman that it was
a confusing presentation and
that we hadn't had a a briefing
a concise enough briefing for for the
subject that we were discussing
okay we have rectified that now but um
is everyone happy with that change
cancer beer
uh yeah well as i've proposed that i'm
quite happy to accept that because i do
feel that the new members uh perhaps
did need a bit more information um and
certainly for us older ones have been
honored
and this sort of thing um we also need
to be updated so
i do fully support um marvel movies
requests
but that should be added in the minutes
and i accept that as part of my proposal
thank you all right should should i have
a officer should i have a vote on that
that we're
going to add this to the minutes we need
a second one
yeah we'll do a second or two the
amendment to the minutes
yeah me
so yeah suez
okay is that all right with your offices
can we add that
yes thank you yes yes chair and you've
got all the information you need on this
now yeah
yep thank you all right so now we want
peter's proposed it so we've got a
second or two minutes now
with the change
yes margaret mayberry seconder
all right thank you um i think uh
karen will now do a roll call for a
minute is that right
thank you chair members if you can reply
with four against or abstain
councillor suez four
councillor peter beer four
councillor jane gould four councillor
margaret mabry
four and councillor mark newman
four thank you chair that's carries
okay the minutes of the meeting have
been confirmed and will be
signed at the next practical opportunity
right is there any petitions aaron
none received chair uh questions from
the public
none received okay we now move to paper
blr stroke 19 stroke eight licensing act
203 statement of licensing
policy statutory five-year review
so can the officer give a report please
thank you chair um this report refers to
the policy setting under the licensing
act 2003
since november 2005 local licensing
authorities have been responsible for
functions under the licensing act
2003 including issuing of licenses and
authorizations for licensed
activities premises clubs events and
individuals
section 5 of the licensing act 2003
requires that the licensing authority
shall determine and publish
a local statement of licensing policy
relating to the discharge of its
licensing functions under the act
in 2020 the authority is due to revisit
the statement that has been in effect
since january 2016
and this report seeks the approval of a
first draft revision
in order that a statutory consultation
period may then commence on its content
this is a statutory function the
licensing team has today
undertaken the necessary preparatory
work within existing resources
and by working together with partner
authorities the resource coordination of
activity and costs associated with the
consultation process
will be shared between the two districts
and wider wherever viable
in general terms the legislation aims to
secure full cost recovery of
administering licensing act 2003
functions
through fees payable for license
applications and ongoing maintenance
the fee banding system and fee levels
are currently set by central government
via regulation
this will be the fifth edition of the
council's statement of licensing policy
under the licensing act 2003. the
licensing team has the necessary
experience
stakeholder contacts and networking in
place to ensure that a wide and balanced
consultation takes place
the consultation will take place over a
minimum period of four weeks
through various channels and media a
joint notice may also be placed in the
local press as part of this engagement
process
adoption of the licensing act 2003
statement of licensing policy
is a function reserved for full council
at this authority
the recommendations are that the draft
revision licensing act
2003 statement of licensing policy
document attached as appendix a
be approved and further that the
relevant officers proceed with the
commencement of a period of statutory
consultation
in accordance with licensing act 2003
legislation
and regulations the committee is able to
resolve this matter
and that concludes the report care thank
you catherine
is there any points of clarification for
members
uh sue you've got your hand up i don't
know
who heirs no
peter beer thank you
um yes i i put a little question mark
against fees and i gather i gather there
um dictated by central government the
fees
um but i i think i'm a bit out of touch
with some of these
is there any way we can have an update
of what these fees are
um because i'm assuming uh there's
certain fees for
um scrap iron
establishments isn't that and there's
another different fee for
um a game
licensed um betting shops and gaming
places and things like that
is there any way we can have this
simplified and sent out to us
and thank you yes councillor we can send
you out the um
the current fair tables for all of the
different areas but at the moment we're
just focusing on the licensing act 2003
um the other areas you mentioned fall
under different legislation
oh but you said that this reviews the
fees so i'm assuming that
if we agree to this we agree to having
these fees
increase because they don't go down um
and that will come back to us i assume
in due course but i'd like to know what
they are before we get to that stage
um this is just to review the the
licensing act 2003 policy
the fees are set as you quite rightly
said by by government so we don't have
any involvement in the setting of
licensing fees
so it wouldn't be much behind us now and
that at this moment then is that what
you're really saying
um it's not going to make a difference i
don't think to the policy no
that's not actually sure i could ever
agree but i i have to vote your wisdom
on that
yeah any more points of clarification
yes um oh yes i've got my hand done
i thought yeah margaret um thank you uh
could
the officers actually confirm that the
fees that we collect
does indeed cover our costs please
uh catherine can you come back on that
or is that still another point
um i believe that the reason that the
fees are set statutorily is that
they are set that way in order to cover
the costs of of
all aspects of licensing act policy
just just for uh caffeine
could we send a copy of fees out to this
committee
i i can't send a copy out yeah that that
would be fine send it out by email to
all members is that
okay peter and marvin would you be happy
with that
yeah yeah yeah yes yes it is
um but just to clarify the officers
cannot
confirm at this present moment in time
that the fees do
do cover all our costs
catherine can you david would you be
able to shed any light on this
please
okay um as far as i'm aware counselor
maybe that the fees that we collect
under lighting act do cover our costs
okay there's your answer marvin thank
you
okay any more points on clarification
right we'll move to debate is there any
um
questions about the paper
i'll just say i i did note that um
there's the hairdressers
get a drinks license and i thought oh
that's strange but actually now like
when they have a wedding
they might give a glass of champagne or
something like that they now have to
have a license for it
is that correct catherine
um that is that is correct if they are
planning on
giving alcohol as part of the the
service they're essentially paying for
it so they would need to be licensed for
that yeah
there you go that's just one night any
questions from anyone else
peter peter yeah um just just wanted
is there any
i um what i was going to say now i'm
sorry it's gone and i've come back
thank you thank you um
considering my my experience in in this
field
regarding uh weddings etc um
i would like to point out to the
committee that um
people who are getting married are not
allowed
officially to be seen to be um
what shall i say under the influence of
alcohol
otherwise a registrar or
someone from the clergy can
deny the wedding okay thank you for that
mostly interesting right is there any
more um
for the debate yeah peter's remembered
his question peter
well i didn't forgot it because yeah it
was to do with the
um times
is there can you tell us
i don't know if they're all the same now
but what are the
licensing regulation hours
on uh pubs hotels
um off licenses things like that because
i think they're they can all be
different can't they
or or depends on their opening hours i
just
uh get confused on all of that
and as you say if there was a
hairdressers and they were doing
wedding hairs and they had some
champagne they had a license
what are they what are the times for
these are they all different or are they
set time testos is the answer
it's most likely to tell you that thank
you and yeah
oh catherine you've got an answer yeah
yeah each each license
each um applicant chooses what they um
think would be best for their business
in terms of licensing hours conditions
and how they're intending to operate so
um
that's why they are they are all
different there isn't a set um
time structure for premises so what is
the time then
say for a pub to open because most of
them are all the same i assume aren't
they
um so i i assume it's eleven till eleven
is that right or is that wrong no most
of
as i say most it's a case-by-case basis
each applicant applies for what that
what they
what they want it we only really bring
it to committee
if we incur representations as part of
the
application process um
so if there's issues with the timings in
regards to the local feeling
then it comes to you guys to make a
decision um but
at the moment most of the time it's it's
it's set by the um
individual applicant so they're all
different people depending on the
circumstances
yeah i understand that now but when
somebody
sort of remember the public talks to
about it or it's got a complaint or not
uh they'll say well it was open at this
time and then
to that time well i've no idea whether
that's right or wrong whether they've
gone over their time limit or not
and then you can contact the licensing
officer yeah i know but that doesn't
help on that spur of the moment
the licenses are all accessible via our
website we do have
them all on our on our licensing system
but we are always
uh willing to answer any queries that
anybody has
so peter you can steer them to the
website
right thank you that's brilliant
um yes thank you um i've got uh two
queries really um on
the um appendix a
at 14.2.1 it speaks of firearms and
weapons um does this need
any clarification or is that just
general i'll give them to you all and
then perhaps you can answer together
14.2.6 f um
you've got and or should there be an
um an oblique between those it's just a
matter of my
uh brain and grammar etc um
14.3.3 l
it says maintenance and repair and i'm
querying
of what
just getting the document in front of me
okay
so in regards to the inclusion of
firearms
um this was something that came about as
part of the section 182
update um which is the home office
guidance that we
closely link our policy to um
so is it possible to get a reminder of
the other um
points i'm afraid i wasn't quick enough
to write them down 14.2.6
f should that be and stroke or
rather than and or
okay and then 14.3.3
l
0.3.3 l it says maintenance and repair
maintenance and repair of what
because um giving a scenario you could
set
you could ask for a maintenance and
repair of
because it's raining gutters or is this
a maintenance and repair of
um equipment such as the um
the pipes for beer
i don't know what you call those things
to go that goes from the beer kegs to
the um
to whatever it is the lever on on the
bar
what is that for please
okie dokie i'll just have a look for you
won't be a moment
okay
catherine is that from the section 182
did we take that i can't remember
it maybe i'm just getting the the policy
up the one i have
in front of me
just to help you if i may mr chairman um
is this maintenance and
repair for health and safety reasons is
this
maintenance and repair for um food
safety because that drink comes under
food and that's what i'm querying
sorry the computer system's very slow
today
i can understand that my mobile phone is
completely
gone off did obviously didn't like the
thunder
and lightning earlier
did you say 14.3
0.3 yes 14.3 and then 0.33 and then it's
l l for laura alpha
lima right
i haven't got the document in front of
me so
i don't have that on my document that's
why i was a bit confused
um margaret do you think could we
could the officers look this up and give
you the information at a later date
would that
be satisfactory for you and it would but
i
it really does need clarification before
it goes out for consultation
because otherwise i feel that consultees
will be querying this as well
what is this maintenance and repair of
david can you shed any light on that one
because we did all go through this
statement and it obviously hasn't been
picked up by any of us so you me
chair can we come back to this can we
can i have a look at the section 182
guidance and we come back to this point
yeah yeah okay we'll come back to this
in a minute margaret okay
okay thank you is there any oh peter b
has got a question
peter oh no i haven't uh
sorry i haven't put my hand down
all right anyone anyone else got any
questions
right so um we've got we can't i want to
propose in a second of it we want do we
want the answer for margaret first
david
so yeah i'm just getting to the relevant
part i found that
it's 2.11 of this section one like two
guidance it speaks of maintenance and
power just having a quick read
yeah well let's do that and we'll have a
breather for a second
okay chair it would be very quick then
um
it's everything it's maintenance and
repair of equipment
fixtures on the premises safety
and satisfactory nature of all of them
so it's certificates of everything so
it's
everything not just one single item so
it's making us repair
the whole premises okay are you happy
with that margaret
uh yes i am thank you very much thank
you
thank you quite helpful can you have a
proposal please
yes i'll propose that peter be a
proposal a second down
yes margaret maybe seconder
right um any more debate
no right i'll ask them karen to go on
with
the boat please
hello
is karen there sorry i was on mute and i
was trying to find the right place all
at the same time sorry
yeah can we can we we've got a proposal
and we've got a second
okay so the recommendation
is that the draft revision licensing act
2003
statement of licensing policy document
attached as appendix a be approved
further that the relevant officers
proceed with the commencement of a
period
of statutory consultation in accordance
with the licensing act
2003 legislation and regulations
i'll now take the roll call call vote
remember
sorry mr chairman i do apologize um
how how long um will it be
for consultation and when would the
final
end date stop being
when it takes effect
um we're sending it out for consultation
on the 20th of august
um and we will be finishing the
consultation on the 16th of september
and we're hoping to bring it back to um
this committee
um after that consultation period um for
you to
see the the post consultation report and
apprentices
thank you are you satisfied peter okay
hate right thank you chair
members please can you reply with four
against or abstain
councillor suez four councillor peter
beer
four councillor sean dawson
councillor jane gould poor councillor
margaret mabry
councillor mark newman
thank you chair that's unanimous that's
carried okay right well i thank you all
for attending this meeting
and that's the end thank you very much
you